[Musique]
une paire de sabots
deux paires de sabots puis 3-4 5-6
encore toujours des sabots mais alors ça
beau pas mort
et non je sais pas moi qui tu as oublié
cannois oui
ne vous dérangez pas monsieur nous
venons d'apprendre à faire des sabots
[Musique]
non seulement ne revient petit à petit
et a mordu et les autres alors nous
aurons pour faire des chapeaux qui est
reproché dans l'union n'est ce pas et
qui a produit ce pour faire résonner en
principe permettre mais celui là il ne
faut compter que de faire et chapeau de
femmes ou enfants et santé
[Musique]
les présentations à droite monsieur
antoine fauré 58 ans il a commencé le
métier à 14 ans je vais monsieur
mongrain
[Musique]
monsieur montbrun 72 ans qui lui même a
débuté le métier à présent
[Musique]
une respiration monsieur antoine et on
recommence
[Musique]
le début chage avec les pôles de moutons
et
oh ce n'est pas fini
[Musique]
le parent war est l'outil de la taille
m
[Musique]
oui
où
père de sabo votre miss paris 2009 en
2000 par 15000
[Musique]
je ferai présente à nouveau amis les
cuillères voilà la valine 18 16 14 13
buts 11 et 9
[Musique]
c'est le creusage avec les cuillères
le moment est crucial il fait le papier
comme le vérifier pour moi ça va
[Musique]
c'est que monsieur mongrain à trois
mille sabots davance
[Musique]
mais
il a vous
étrange
[Musique]
alors que le 1er juin
à oui c'est pas pareil sauf s'ils
chantent amoyel femmes se sont déjà
posés dimanche dimanche
dimanche l'un finhan qui a toujours
connu la vocation sabotière
et maintenant chacune chacun trouve ça
beau à son pied l'abri des mises
[Musique]
oh
où vont-ils tous nos sabots peut être
lancée sur la musique de notre rondo ou
peut-être attendre devant les cheminées
la venue du père noël
[Musique]
et parmi ces enfants y aura-t-il un jour
le successeur de monsieur forêt tout
simple mais si pur artisans
[Musique]
du sabot